dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly affair in many
episodes about computer graphics we
explored works on how to simulate the
motion and the collision of different
bodies however sounds are just as
important as visuals and there are
really cool techniques out there that
take the geometry and material
description of such objects and they
simulate how smashing them together
would sound like this one is a more
sophisticated method which is not only
faster than previous works but can
simulate a greater variety of materials
and we can also edit the solutions
without needing to recompute the
expensive equations that yield the sound
as a result the faster part comes from a
set of optimizations most importantly
something that is called mesh
simplification this means that the
simulations are done not on the original
but vastly simplified shapes the result
of this simplified simulation is close
to indistinguishable from the real deal
that is considerably cheaper to compute
what is really cool is that the
technique also offers editing
capabilities you compute the simulation
only once and then edit and explore as
much as you desire the stiffness and
damping parameters can be edited without
any additional work quite a few
materials can be characterized with this
the model can also approximate a quite
sophisticated phenomenon where the
frequency of a sound is changing in time
one can for instance specify stiffness
values that vary in time to produce
these cruel frequency shifting effects
it is also possible to exaggerate or
dampen different frequencies of these
sound effects and these results are
given to you immediately
this is meeting all my standards amazing
piece of work thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time